♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE WORLD'S MOST
FAMOUS 29-YEAR-OLD CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IS
FACING NEW ALLEGATIONS THAT SHE
VIOLATED CAMPAIGN FINANCE.
NEWLY FILED D.C. COMPLAINT THE
CONGRESSWOMAN AND CHIEF AND
CHIEF OF STAFF ILLEGAL SUBSIDY
SCHEME.
THEY RAN A NETWORK OF POLITICAL
ACTION COMMITTEES.
THE COMPLAINT SAID THIS ALLOWED
HER TO RAISE MORE MONEY THAN SHE
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO LEGALLY.
A FOX BUSINESS ANCHOR, COHOST
OUT NUMBER AND FREQUENT GUEST ON
THE SHOW AND VERY GOOD AT
DETAILS AND SO COME ON AND
EXPLAIN WHAT THIS COMPLAINT
SAID.
>> WELL, I READ THE COMPLAINT
AND THE WAY IT READS, IT IS
ACTUALLY A VERY CLEVER SCHEME.
IT LOOKED LIKE THEY SET UP A
COMPANY AND YOU COULD SORT OF BE
ADVENTURE INVESTOR IN THE
COMPANY.
THE LOOPER OF POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS SO ANYONE COULD KIND O
CAMPAIGNS SO ANYONE COULD KIND F
COME UP AND START THEIR
CAMPAIGN AND YOU GET POLITICAL
SERVICES WAY BELOW MARKET
PRICES.
THE PROBLEM IS THE COMPANY WENT
OUT OF BUSINESS IT SEEMS FROM
THE COMPLAINT.
THAT IS HOW IT READS AND ALL
ALLEGED, BUT THE COMPANY
BASICALLY SPENT MOST OF ITS
MONEY ON HER CAMPAIGN.
THE INVESTORS, NEVER GOT
ANYTHING BACK.
THEY JUST HELPED HER CAMPAIGN.
SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT THAT IN
THE WORST LIGHT, IT SOUNDS LIKE
IF YOU WERE A FINANCE SMART
MONEY GUY AND HER CHIEF OF STAFF
AND THE PHOTO IS A
MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
I'M SURE YOU'RE CHIEF OF STAFF
IS ALSO VERY WEALTHY BUT I DON'T
KNOW HOW, AND THAT IS BUT
ANYWAY, MONEY AND SET UP THIS
COMPANY.
IS IT ILLEGAL?
WHO KNOWS.
AS I SAID BEFORE, THE PEOPLE WHO
WRITE THE LAWS ABOUT CAMPAIGN
FINANCE ARE GOOD POLITICIANS
TRYING TO HANG ONTO POWER.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT WRITE THE
LAW.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS ILLEGAL
OR IF THE COMPLAINT BROUGHT BY
CONSERVATIVE GROUP.
THAT IS HER DEFENSE, THIS IS THE
RIGHT ATTACKING HER.
WE WILL SEE HOW THE
INVESTIGATION GOES.
BUT I THINK THE MAIN POINT, SHE
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT GETTING
MONEY OUT OF POLITICS AND
TRANSPARENCY, WHERE'S THE MONEY
COMING FROM AND WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IS MORE AND MORE EVIDENCE
THAT SHE'S GOT ALL KINDS OF
MONEY THAT HELPED HER GET
ELECTED.
AND IT WAS MURKY AND SHADY.
NOTHING TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING IS
IRONY.
THAT IS WHAT I'M STARTING TO
SUSPECT.
>> Melissa: AND HYPOCRISY.
>> Tucker: AND HYPOCRISY.
>> Melissa: HYPOCRISY
ABOUNDING EVERYWHERE.
KEEP AN EYE ON IT AND YOU
REMEMBER SHE SET UP LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANY SO YOU COULD
NOT HOW THE MONEY WAS THINGS
SPENT.
WE WANT TO BE FAIR.
LET'S SEE HOW THE INVESTIGATIONS
TURN OUT BUT THEY SEEM TO AT THE
VERY LEAST, YOU KNOW BE THE DARK
MONEY THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT
BEING EVIL AND GETTING RID OF
THE DARK MONEY UNLESS HELPING
THE CAMPAIGN, I DON'T KNOW.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> Melissa: I HATE HYPOCRITES.
>> Melissa: I DO TOO,
MELISSA FRANCIS, GREAT TO SEE
YOU TONIGHT.